[Música]
comenzó oficialmente el mundial de Qatar
2022 Y nuevamente la polémica está por
encima del deleite Deportivo el mundo
occidental se ha cerrado en cierta
manera en un bloque para recriminar a la
sede de la copa del mundo por su
desempeño en materia de derechos
laborales con los llamados empleados
golondrinas y de derechos humanos y
derechos de las minorías pero es la
sociedad occidental el estandarte el
ejemplo a seguir con toda la capacidad
moral para exigir y criticar acatar la
doble moral es de la sociedad occidental
ha quedado expuesta una vez más en esta
competencia deportiva y lo peor aún la
incapacidad del mundo occidental de
aceptar y tolerar que catar es un país
con una cultura una cosmovisión y una
perspectiva de su lugar en el mundo que
occidente no ha podido entender o por lo
menos le ha costado un poco entenderlo
solo lo ha comprendido Cuando llega la
hora de negociar por gas O por petróleo
ahí sí se ponen de acuerdo
el último en echarle más leña a esta
hoguera fue el presidente de la FIFA ya
en infantino tienen unas declaraciones
destacó los avances experimentados en
Qatar en materia social y también en
materia de los Derechos Humanos
escuchemos hoy me siento catari hoy me
siento árabe hoy me siento africano hoy
me siento gay hoy me siento
discapacitado hoy me siento un
trabajador migrante
Cuántos de estos empresarios empresas
europeas u occidentales Cuántas de ellas
han abordado los derechos de los
trabajadores migrantes esta lección
moral queda unilateral es por hipocresía
pues las declaraciones de infantino
avivaron El Debate sobre el hecho de que
catarse a la sede de un evento que es
netamente deportivo Pero también es un
evento que es netamente occidental La
pregunta es el mundo apenas ahora se dio
cuenta de esas deudas pendientes que
tiene Qatar en materia de Derechos
Humanos Porque lo venden a decir apenas
ahora la sede fue asignada hace ya
muchos años atrás porque se le asignó
Qatar a la sede del mundial si hay tanto
reclamo sociales porque no se les
criticó igual en su momento a Rusia o a
Brasil o a Sudáfrica cuando fueron sede
del mundial el mismo gobierno dijo que
nunca se podía haber imaginado un boicot
internacional como el que está viviendo
en este momento justo cuando está
comenzando la copa está la sociedad
occidental en posición de venir a
criticar y a reclamarle moralidad acatar
el Mundial de la hipocresía es nuestro
tema de debate en France 24 y hacemos
este programa porque semanas atrás
también un debate en el que analizamos
todas estas controversias y críticas que
había sobre Qatar por eso vale la pena
ver La otra cara de la moneda en que
está fallando la sociedad occidental a
la hora de tener un poco de tolerancia
apertura y entender que catar es un país
musulmán que está en medio oriente y que
tal vez no está dentro de la cosmovisión
del mundo occidental para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a Santiago Mena él
es asistente de investigación para las
Américas en human right watch él se
conecta desde la ciudad de Montevideo en
Uruguay y también está con nosotros
Julio chiapetta él es periodista
especializado en temas deportivos
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden ser parte de este debate pueden
dejar todos los comentarios y las
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter en Facebook en
instagram no se encuentran como arroba
el
debate_f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios es numeral el debate f24 no
se olviden también que todos los
contenidos del programa también están
disponibles en Apple podcast estamos
también en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
muy bien Le doy la bienvenida entonces a
Santiago para comenzar este debate y
conocer las posiciones en torno a este
tema y comienzo entonces Santiago
Bienvenido al programa retomando esas
palabras esas declaraciones de gianni
infantino que balance puede hacer usted
de estas declaraciones donde le
recrimina mucho la posición que está
tomando el mundo occidental con todo
este zartal de críticas hacia Qatar
Muchas gracias Santiago Gracias por
tenerme en el programa sí las
declaraciones de infantino son extrañas
Es un poco esta crítica a la posición de
occidente te voy a dejar bien en claro
human Rich watch viene documentando la
situación de derechos humanos y
monitoreando esta situación en Qatar ya
desde antes de 2010 es cuando la FIFA le
da a pesar de los pésimos antecedentes
en materia de Derechos Humanos los
derechos para ser anfitrión del mundial
acatar Y en este monitoreo de los
Derechos Humanos es que hemos detectado
las distintas situaciones los distintos
abusos contra los grupos en Qatar ya
sean los trabajadores migrantes ya sean
las personas lgbt las mujeres y la
situación de la libertad de expresión la
libertad de prensa la libertad
asociación Entonces es importante
remarcar este punto y también con
respecto a la introducción que hacías
este monitoreo de los derechos humanos y
la documentación de los abusos de las
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos que
se viven en Qatar ya desde hace muchos
años y acá también importante los
Derechos Humanos son universales nos
competen a todas las personas por el mil
simple hecho de ser personas
documenta las violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos ya sea en catar ya sea en Rusia
en Brasil en Estados Unidos en Argentina
hacemos el monitoreo en los distintos
países pedí una óptica de objetividad
Independencia siendo lo más rigurosos
posibles en estas documentaciones y en
esta documentaciones es con el modo
detectado abusos en Qatar contra los
trabajadores migrantes que son
trabajadores principalmente del de Asia
de países como la India nepal bangladesh
tener en cuenta que más del 90% de la
fuerza laboral catarín son extranjeros y
los abusos que detectamos contra ellos
incluyen la falta de pago en sus
salarios lesiones e incluso muertes que
no han sido debidamente investigadas por
las autoridades cataríes Este es el
pedido de The human richwatch y otras
organizaciones a nivel internacional a
que la FIFA y acatar establezcan un
fondo de compensación para indemnizar a
estos trabajadores que sufrieron abusos
para indemnizar a las familias en el
caso de los trabajadores que han
fallecido vamos a profundizar en ese
tema Santiago Quiero ver la otra
perspectiva de este asunto del lado
deportivo finalmente esto es un evento
mundial la escala mundial es un mundial
de fútbol pero es un evento netamente
occidental Quiero conocer entonces la
opinión de nuestro siguiente invitado
Julio que se encuentra en la ciudad de
Buenos Aires Julio Bienvenido al
programa Gracias por acompañarnos hoy y
cuál es su análisis las declaraciones
que da hayan infantino sobre esta forma
en que el mundo occidental ha manejado
el tema de los Derechos Humanos en Qatar
y y digamos que este boicot que ha
habido a lo largo de los últimos días
contrasta sede de la copa del mundo
Hola Santiago Buenas noches gracias por
la invitación yo le preguntaría al Señor
Jenny fantino este o le recordaría Mejor
dicho un viejo refrán que dice lo que
empieza mal termina mal y le
recomendaría también que vea el
documental
los hombres que compraron la Copa del
Mundo basado en la investigación de dos
periodistas del sundaytam ingleses que
este dieron inicio a lo que se conoció
como el FIFA gay así este está
documentado
explícitamente porque
Qatar fue sede de este mundial
2022 partiendo de esa base entonces ahí
no podemos hablar de hipocresía de
occidente sino de un hecho turbio que le
otorgó la sede al país árabe
Julio en ese orden de ideas Entonces qué
pensaba la FIFA o por lo menos que fue
lo que dijo ante la comunidad
internacional para haber seleccionado
acatar como la sede del mundial Cuáles
fueron los argumentos
los argumentos se ven en el documental
primero sarkozy presionando a Miguel
platini Para que apoye a Qatar a cambio
de que los cataríes se hagan cargo de su
Club favorito el psg cosa que ocurrió y
también la la compra de 50 años este al
del gobierno cataría el gobierno francés
también este se expresa en ese
documental
como
Joseph platter este resistió hasta
último momento hasta dimitir la sede de
Qatar elegida diciendo que el mundial
podía jugarse en otra fecha como
finalmente ocurrió no se juega a mitad
de temporada como es habitual sino por
primera y creo que única vez en la
historia de los mundiales este se juega
a final de temporada con la consecuencia
que ha tenido en los futbolistas con la
gran cantidad de lesionados no hace
falta nombrar que más se pierde el
mundial por base pierde el mundial sabio
amanece pierde el mundial
elso se pierde el mundial Por qué Porque
en octubre fue un mes masacre se jugaba
cada tres días por cosas importantes
tanto en la temporada europea como en el
resto del mundo claro Santiago hay algo
que yo quiero entender regreso con
nuestro invitado en la ciudad de
Montevideo usted me decía en su
intervención anterior que ya desde hace
un buen tiempo han venido estudiando
esas deficiencias en cuanto al manejo de
los empleados extranjeros en Qatar en la
falta de cuidado a la hora de garantizar
derechos humanos para algunas de las
minorías o para algunos sectores de la
sociedad catari Esto no es nuevo
Entonces por qué apenas hasta ahora se
arma un escándalo internacional por
estas denuncias que están haciendo
cuando ustedes vienen haciendo un
recuento una investigación de años atrás
antes del 2010 cuando Qatar Recibió la
sede de la Copa no obviamente Santiago
con mientras se acerca y ahora que ya
estamos jugando el mundial crece el
interés de la comunidad internacional en
saber qué es lo que pasa entonces
también por un lado mucho de las de las
preguntas vienen qué va a pasar con
respecto a los hinchas a la delegaciones
internacionales que visiten Qatar
durante el Mundial Y eso creo que es una
oportunidad
sí no me escucha ahí sí perfecto
adelante sí no que eso es una
oportunidad para que la comunidad
internacional tenga noción Sobre qué es
lo que pasa en Qatar en el día a día no
solo durante el Mundial y es donde van a
estar los ojos sino que es lo que ha
pasado antes y qué es lo que va a pasar
durante Pues también ahí es importante
hablar de cuál va a ser el legado de
este mundial si el legado de este
mundial va a ser los abusos laborales va
a ser la represión contra minorías como
las mujeres como las personas lgbt o si
el legado de este mundial y por eso el
empuje para que FIFA para que Qatar
tomen medidas sean cambios estructurales
van a ser reformas a largo plazo que
garanticen los derechos de estas
personas que garanticen que los
trabajadores migrantes no vean más
abusos tengan mejores condiciones
laborales que las mujeres puedan ejercer
sus derechos libremente que las personas
tengan respecto a sus derechos Pero
porque eso no antes porque ahora porque
no exigirlo antes para que cuando
llegara la sede del mundial y comenzar
al mundial a haber visto los cambios y
haber dicho bueno
Qatar hizo en 15 años una transformación
debido a estas críticas a nivel
internacional y aquí se ven los
resultados porque justo ahora no Sí yo
creo que es un gran sector de la
comunidad internacional ya venía
exigiendo estos cambios lo que pasa y
que creo que es común con respecto a a
los medios y el interés de la opinión
pública Mientras más se acercaba al
mundial y ahora que está sucediendo el
mundial ese interés en saber qué es lo
que pasa en Qatar crece Entonces si bien
criticamos la decisión de la FIFA en
2010 de con los pésimos antecedentes que
tenía
Qatar darle los derechos para hacer
anfitrión ahora no sirve como una
oportunidad para que la comunidad
internacional vea qué es lo que pasa qué
es lo que viven día a día los cataríes y
la excusa es de con los hinchas con las
delegaciones profesionales que lo
visitan también experimentar en carne
propia y ver qué es lo que sucede en ese
país
Ya regreso con usted Santiago Quiero
preguntarle a Julio en la ciudad de
Buenos Aires sobre el impacto que tiene
esto a nivel deportivo a nivel del
disfrute de deporte de una competencia
sana porque se critica a las elecciones
que van a ir se critica a los
deportistas a los futbolistas que son
estrellas a nivel internacional porque
están jugando en territorio catarí
también se les está recriminando mucho a
las elecciones a los países que van a
jugar y a los jugadores esto como van
detrimento de el deporte como tal
en eso concuerdo con vos Se le pide a
los jugadores lo que no hacen los
dirigentes Se le pide a los artistas
algunos se negaron a participar de la
ceremonia inaugural figuras
dua lipa o Shakira
Maluma participó el sábado en el fan
festival y no el domingo en la ceremonia
inaugural que fue muy insulsa no sé qué
te pareció a vos Santiago pero me
pareció que no fue una ceremonia
inaugural futbolística sino me pareció
más un show de Coldplay con las luces de
colores y los efectos este luminosos
futbolísticamente hasta ahora lo que se
vio fue auspicioso porque se vieron
muchos goles en las dos primeras
jornadas algunas elecciones que
sorprendieron por ejemplo Estados Unidos
hoy en el primer tiempo ante gales y
Inglaterra que dio un festival también
lo que se ve en lo deportivo es que
algunas elecciones se animan a enfrentar
a las autoridades de la FIFA que
amenazan con
sanciones a los que protesten y por
ejemplo la selección de Inglaterra
se arrodilló antes del partido en
protesta contra el racismo y la de Irán
no cantó el himno el repudio a lo que
está sucediendo con las mujeres en su
país esas son pequeñas muestras que
ayudan a visibilizar
todo los atropellos a los Derechos
Humanos que Santiago en Montevideo en
Uruguay estaba reseñando muy pero muy
bien
Santiago uno mira La coyuntura
Internacional en este momento y ve que
hay una crisis energética importante
sobre todo para el hemisferio norte que
está a la puerta del inicio del Invierno
boreal estamos hablando de Europa
Estados Unidos Canadá países que que van
a tener un invierno muy difícil sobre
todo en Europa por la falta de petróleo
y gas sabemos que
Qatar es justamente uno de los países
con las mayores reservas de gas después
de Rusia y de Irán aquí este tema que
tanto se está manipulando para que el
gobierno catari tenga que acercarse a
esos gobiernos occidentales para
decirles Oiga Déjenme hacer la copa en
paz déjeme tranquilo y el otro le diga
Bueno yo te dejo atacar pero vendeme gas
está haciendo esto un arma de
manipulación para lograr negociaciones
con esos países ya veíamos al Reino
Unido haciendo negociaciones con Qatar y
con lazerbaiyán que también es un país
muy criticado en tema de Derechos
Humanos pero están los ingleses
comprando gas y nadie les dice nada no
es importante Santiago que en las
discusiones y en las presiones que se
hacen los Derechos Humanos estén en el
centro de la discusión Más allá de esta
cuestión geopolítica y los intereses de
los países los derechos humanos tienen
que estar en el centro de la discusión
por eso también esta crítica a FIFA
cuando hace unas semanas le mandó una
carta a las asociaciones de fútbol
diciendo concéntrense en el fútbol no no
tiene que ser así porque las cuestiones
de derechos humanos tienen que estar y
se tienen que discutir y nosotros no
negamos Y creo que es importante marcar
que no es incompatible el deseo el
anhelo la pasión de los hinchas y estas
cuestiones que relacionaba Julio sobre
las cuestiones profesionales de los
músicos artistas con Levantar la voz por
los reclamos justos y legítimos de los
trabajadores migrantes de exigir que se
respeten los derechos humanos de todas
las personas en Qatar para mujeres de
las personas lgbt no hay una
incompatibilidad ahí no estamos haciendo
un juicio de valor sobre el hincha y su
fanatismo y su anhelo de ver a la
selección que sea levantar la copa del
mundo pero sí pedimos así como le
pedimos a la FIFA que no es solo una
obligación moral la FIFA tiene una
obligación con respecto a su propia
política de derechos humanos con
respecto a principios que adoptó del
derecho internacional de poner esta
discusión y de exigirle en este caso
acatar que cumpla con compromisos de
derechos humanos y también las
asociaciones de fútbol lo tienen y por
eso recalcamos y es muy importante lo
que hacen asociaciones de fútbol como la
Inglaterra la de Francia la de Estados
Unidos que apoyan este pedido para que
se crea un fondo de compensación
mientras las de América Latina mientras
Argentina Brasil Uruguay y el resto de
las clasificadas se quedan en un
silencio vergonzoso y no se pronuncian
ni sobre el pedido para crear este fondo
de compensación sí sobre la situación de
Derechos Humanos en Qatar Santiago
Perdón Julio Cuál es su opinión sobre
sobre este punto en particular que trae
Santiago a la mesa las elecciones tienen
que tomar una parte tienen
es compatible esto que las elecciones
tengan que tomar una posición frente a
estos temas finalmente son deportistas
es que no son activistas no son líderes
políticos son una selección de fútbol
yo creo que eso rige la conciencia de
cada uno de los futbolistas Sería muy
bueno que las grandes estrellas de las
elecciones sudamericanas también se
sumen a este pedido de respeto para las
minorías de rechazo contra el racismo de
que se investiguen la cantidad de
muertos que hubo en la construcción de
los estadios en para el mundial de Qatar
creo que sería muy bueno pero eso queda
en la conciencia de cada persona el
derecho humano es universal pero es
individual cada uno hace lo que puede y
lo que le dejan hacer o lo que le dicta
la conciencia no sé si Santiago en
Montevideo
concordará con mi opinión Santiago que
responde usted
no estoy de acuerdo no estamos acá
nosotros para hacer juicio de valor con
respecto por ejemplo a lo que es la
cuestión es individuales de los
jugadores pero sí las asociaciones de
fútbol como decía la FIFA tiene su
propia política de Derechos Humanos las
asociaciones de fútbol están obligadas
también a cumplir con esa política de
Derechos Humanos que establece que los
compromisos en materia de Derechos
Humanos que adopta la FIFA son
obligatorios para todos sus órganos para
todas sus personas y eso también
comprende a las asociaciones de fútbol y
creo que es importante también recordar
que las asociaciones de fútbol se ven
beneficiadas económicamente por la
realización del mundial entonces creo
que hacer por ejemplo apoyar este pedido
de que se crea un fondo de compensación
a quienes hicieron posible el mundial
estamos hablando de los trabajadores que
con su esfuerzo construyeron no solo los
estadios sino también construyeron los
restaurantes los hoteles aeropuertos
todo para que hoy disfrutemos el mundial
entonces Creo que este pedido a que
estas asociaciones de fútbol se
pronuncien en favor de estos derechos es
importante y no me parece que sea
simplemente una cuestión moral o ética
sino que también hay obligaciones que se
imponen sí es una cuestión económica
porque hasta ahora no hemos visto
ninguna Asociación de Fútbol decide
públicamente no vamos al mundial Porque
defendemos estos valores vamos en contra
de lo que sucede en Qatar no vamos a ir
No allá están para facturar también
porque también genera plata entonces
también ve uno ahí esas dos caras de la
moneda en julio en la ciudad de Buenos
Aires ustedes hablaban de los juicios
individuales ha sido completamente
Inevitable que haya críticas a jugadores
por ejemplo como Messi a cantantes como
dua lipa Shakira Incluso el mismo Maluma
por haberse levantado de una de una
entrevista a la televisión israelí en la
que le estaban cuestionando justamente
el tema de los Derechos Humanos en qué
momento al mundo y a la sociedad se nos
desvirtuó en la imagen de estas personas
que son artistas que son deportistas no
son gobernantes ni Defensores de los
Derechos Humanos ni activistas algunos
de ellos lo son muy comprometidos pero
en este caso en particular no es tan
comprometidos con estas causas y la
sociedad les reclama a ellos una
posición cuando ellos están para otro
tipo de cosas
en eso concuerdo por eso hablaba del
derecho individual y déjame decirte que
lo que pide Santiago Mena me parece que
es imposible porque la FIFA están
integradas por cada una de las
federaciones no es un ente autárquico no
es un ente independiente está integrado
por cada una
entonces la federaciones no se van a
tirar en contra de la FIFA Y no van a
hacer lo que lo que pide Santiago y los
futbolistas harán lo que cada uno quiera
hacer en cuanto a su conciencia por eso
yo decía que me parece que es un derecho
individual que cada uno se manifieste
como mejor le plazca Messi solamente
quiere hablar de fútbol dedicarse al
fútbol y este
jugar el su último mundial con la
ilusión de levantar la copa del mundo
que le fue escriba en Brasil 2014
después Este se le podrá criticar si
hace algún tipo de publicidad o contrato
o
adhesiones a empresas cataríes bueno Él
juega en un club que está manejados por
por
fondos y capitales de Qatar Así que ahí
ya no puede hacer absolutamente nada Qué
va a ser Messi contra los que dirigen el
presidente
Sí nada finalmente pues simplemente un
empleado más contratado por un equipo de
fútbol Santiago Qué hay de los países de
procedencia de estos empleados que
durante años se han trasladado a países
del Golfo Pérsico no solamente Qatar
también situaciones similares similares
hemos visto por ejemplo en los emiratos
árabes Unidos sobre esta contratación a
través de un sistema de patrocinio que
hasta donde entiendo Qatar ya lo eliminó
y que ya no están estricto a la hora de
por ejemplo cuando el empleado quiere
cambiar de trabajo o quiere abandonar el
país un sistema que es conocido como
cafala que dicen los países para
proteger a sus ciudadanos está hablando
de nepal India Pakistán bangladesh sri
lanka filipinas donde hay miles de
trabajadores de estos países en estas
condiciones han reclamado en la
comunidad internacional han reclamado
ante los organismos internacionales para
protegerlos o se han quedado tranquilos
porque como mandan remesas a sus países
entonces la situación económica
pues les conviene
Sí es muy importante hizo Santiago
Porque es importante
atacar Cuáles son las cuestiones que
llevan a las personas a migrar Cuáles
son las cuestiones que hacen que una
persona se vaya de su casa se vaya a su
hogar de su país y tenga que ir a otro
país para darle sustento a su familia
para hacer en muchísimos casos la
principal fuente de ingresos para su
familias es importante que los países de
origen de los trabajadores migrantes
tengan y hagan un análisis y respondan
ante Cuáles son las causas que llevan a
esas personas a migrar estos países han
respondido en cierta manera ante esta
situación de los trabajadores migrantes
Estableciendo seguros de indemnización y
dando indemnizaciones a familias en sus
países Pero ha sido muy acotado y esto
que decide las reformas de Qatar al
sistema cafala reconocemos que se han
hecho reformas principalmente desde 2018
pero esas reformas no en el universo
total de trabajadores migrantes llegan
tarde porque si pensamos que se
empezaron a implementar en el 2018 y
Qatar tuvo los derechos desde el 2010
obviamente hay un universo enorme de
trabajadores que no se vio beneficiado
por ellas y el sistema de vigilar como
se implementan estas reformas es
bastante débil por parte de las
autoridades cataríes Entonces todavía
hay un camino larguísimo por recorrer
por Qatar en cuestiones de reformas de
la situación de los trabajadores
migrantes y que FIFA podría ser en lugar
de ser el facilitador complaciente que
fue y de mirar cómo catar abusaba y no
implementaba las reformas necesarias
para mejorar la situación de los
trabajadores migrantes podría haber
empujado y debería haber Porque es
obligación para que catar implemente
estas reformas y sean duraderas en el
largo plazo y lleguen al universo total
de trabajadores y quiero retomar Perdón
Santiago un punto de lo que decía con
respecto a las asociaciones hay
asociaciones de fútbol que ya se han
pronunciado y mencionaba estas de
Inglaterra Francia gales Estados Unidos
Países Bajos hay patrocinadores hay
sponsors oficiales del mundial y de la
FIFA que ya se han pronunciado y que han
apoyado el pedido de creación de este
fondo de compensación McDonald's
coca-cola visa Budweiser hay jugadores
la selección de Australia en su
totalidad ha pedido por la creación de
este fondo ya levantado la voz con
respecto a los a las personas lgbt y a
las mujeres Entonces no es que no han
habido situaciones no han habido
personas no han habido grupos hay y a
Incluso en todo este en el contexto del
beneficio económico que les va a servir
el mundial se están pronunciando Y
nosotros empujamos a que más se
pronuncien y específicamente de América
Latina
Julio regreso con usted en la ciudad de
Buenos Aires el mundial empezó hace muy
poco estamos en la primera fase de los
primeros partidos los el primer
abrebocas digámoslo así de esta fiesta
deportiva pero ya va dejando muchas
reflexiones esta esta competencia
que nos deja acatar de elecciones para
los países sede que vienen en el futuro
con todas estas controversias que ha
habido previo al inicio de la Copa
Primero déjame contestarle a Santiago
que si espera que Messi cavani Neymar o
cualquiera de las estrellas
sudamericanas salgan con un brazalete o
con alguna bandera este
rechazando este el racismo las los
problemas que tienen las comunidades
sexuales minoritarias o
en contra de los trabajadores muertos en
la construcción de los estadios eso no
decir este ni Messi lo va a hacer
tampoco Cristiano Ronaldo para nombrar
otra estrella europea
porque ellos después
firman contratos con esas mismas
empresas para decatar para
su vida
deportiva y lo lo dije claramente Messi
es empleado de fondos cataríes en el psg
ahora en cuanto a lo que nos está
mostrando
Qatar
lo que yo veo son dos cuestiones una
negativa fue la primera vez en un
partido inaugural que al cabo del primer
tiempo más de la mitad del estadio
abandonó las instalaciones y dejó en
evidencia que este Este es un mundial A
ver no digamos trucho que es una palabra
muy fuerte pero sí un mundial raro y la
segunda cuestión
más deportiva que estoy viendo es la
cantidad de tiempo adicionado que se
agrega a los partidos es casi un
entretiempo hay partidos que duraron 15
minutos que tuvieron una adicional de 15
minutos y este eso le viene bien a al
fútbol y a los que gustan de que los
equipos vayan al frente y lo hagan
tiempo
Y eso también se ve en el tiempo al aire
de la producción de televisión que
también es todo un negocio la venta de
los derechos televisivos y para los
canales que transmiten este tipo de
eventos Pues también implica tener un
poco más de tiempo al aire garantizando
un cierto rating alto a lo largo de la
transmisión teniendo 15 minutos de más
eso en televisión tener un rating de 15
minutos más es es
impresionante para las ganancias vamos
llegando al bloque final del programa
quiero que entonces vayamos pensando en
las conclusiones en la reflexión que
podemos hacer general de este de todas
estas críticas de las dos caras de la
moneda en el programa pasado hablamos
netamente de Qatar en este le dimos un
poco más de análisis al tema de
occidente y esta moralidad despertada
exacerbada ahora de occidente por venir
a reclamar un montón de cosas
qué análisis pueden hacer ustedes para
el cierre Qué conclusión les deja hasta
el momento estas dos caras de la moneda
un país tratando de ganarse un
posicionamiento internacional un peso
político y Deportivo internacional y una
comunidad internacional que hace
críticas y un país que tiene una deuda
con los Derechos Humanos a nivel
internacional
Santiago
Sí yo creo Santiago
recapitular Sobre qué es lo que viven
las personas en el día a día en Qatar en
Qatar las relaciones sexuales entre
entre personas del mismo sexo están
criminalizadas los hombres que tengan
relaciones sexuales entre sí pueden
enfrentar penas de prisión de hasta
siete años en
Qatar las mujeres se ven ante un sistema
de tutela masculina que les exige que
para las decisiones más elementales de
su vida sea casarse sea viajar al
exterior sea acceder a un empleo público
tengan que tener el consentimiento de un
hombre sea su padre su tío su primo su
hermano su esposo Entonces estamos
hablando de un ambiente es sumamente
hostil sumamente represivo para el
ejercicio de los derechos de muchas
personas ya hablamos sobre él lo que es
la cuestión de los trabajadores
migrantes entonces también vemos un país
en el que por ejemplo no hay sindicatos
no hay organizaciones que defiendan los
grupos las mujeres de personas lgbt no
porque no haya esas personas en ese país
sino porque no se puede porque está
prohibido estamos hablando de censura y
límites a lo que es la libertad de
prensa a lo que es la libertad
asociación a lo que es la libertad de
expresión Entonces cuando tenemos todo
ese combo de cosas y vemos cómo se han
manejado los actores relevantes Oye el
principal es FIFA ante eso es empujar
desde la comunidad internacional a que
los cambios que Qatar haya hecho y los
que quedan por hacer se hagan sean
duraderos sean a largo plazo sean
estructurales y vayan en el sentido de
respetar el ejercicio y la garantía de
los derechos humanos de todos sus
habitantes Santiago Pero eso no es una
óptica de una visión de una sociedad
occidental A lo mejor Qatar no no le
interesa ser así son valores
occidentales
no no yo no los amaría valores
occidentales los Derechos Humanos son
universales y los tenemos todos por el
hecho de estar personas los tienen los
tengo yo los tenés vos y lo tienen las
mujeres y las personas lgbt en Qatar
Entonces no creo que sea una cuestión de
justificarse en base a la sociedad
Entonces sí creo que es importante que
la comunidad internacional siga
empujando para que los Derechos Humanos
que son universales que son de todos
sean aplicables y puedan ser ejercidos
por todos los habitantes en Qatar Julio
su conclusión para el cierre mi
conclusión es que hay que ponerle fin a
la hipocresía yo no creo que después de
Qatar cambien mucho la situación el
suelo catari por ahí este la presión que
está ejerciendo occidente puede llevar
algunos pequeños cambios pero después
que termine el mundial
Qatar va a seguir haciendo su vida como
siempre y también sus negocios con los
gobiernos de como siempre así que yo le
le pondría un poco de
fin a la hipocresía que se le ponga fin
a la hipocresía de criticar acatar por
un lado y después hacer negocios con el
país por el otro Me parece que
también lo que deja como enseñanza Es
que este cada vez más los derechos
humanos tienen que ser respetados en
todo el mundo en occidente y en Oriente
la conclusión de nuestros invitados
desde la ciudad de Montevideo y la
ciudad de Buenos Aires yo les agradezco
mucho por haber
aceptado a ver esta para estar aquí
haciendo este análisis estas dos caras
de la moneda Muchas gracias Santiago
Muchas gracias Julio ya veremos que nos
deja este mundial en un mes veremos las
conclusiones de todo este debate y de
toda esta controversia a nivel
internacional y luego ya veremos qué
países van a seguir negociando con Qatar
sobre todo cuando empieza el invierno en
el hemisferio norte Quién va a ir a
comprarle entonces gas y se va a olvidar
del tema de los Derechos Humanos ustedes
pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales es todo por el momento En
nombre del equipo Les agradecemos la
sintonía la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Giovanni agudelo y la
producción de invitados a cargo de Tania
Herrera Gracias por seguir con nosotros
[Música]